THE DECK.
>> Bret: WIT OF THE FLAMES
LEAGUE, TO SEE WHAT IS AVAILABLE
FOR THT ISE TONIGHT, ANDN BOTH
GOALS SATURDAY NIGHT
AND MEIERS OKARLSSON HAS
TO HUSTLE BACK, ANR EBERLE, TURD
RRNL SWING IT OVER
HOCKEY LEAGUE.
TRYING TO JUMP BACK IN, AND
SEATTLE E D
VLASIC
R  JAMES
REIMERR AMONG
FORWARDS IN THE NHL IN B BHE NHM
TONIGHT, FOR THE FIRSTVLASIC, IO
THE STICK, AND OVER TOL NAVIGAT
UP, AND STANDS DUNN, GOT
DO ANDE
THIS SEASON TONIGHT.
>> Randy: A QUICK REGROUP.ION BE
SHARKS
COGLIANO, PIVOTS THERE WASN'T A
PENALTY THERE.
IN COMESO JOHANSSON.
AGAINST BURNS, GEEKIE IN TRYING
MAYBE HE GOT AROUND BURNS SON CO
COUTURE.THERE.
>> Randy: MEIER FROM CENTE WELLS
LOOKING FOEAR BOARDS
KARLSSON, OVER TU CAN SEE
OLEKSIAK, RIGHT NOW, CUTS  STICE